[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم بضيوف برنامج
النقاش ويمكنكم كالعاده ان تتفاعلوا مع ما
يقوله ضيوف في برنامج على صفحتنا على
فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
سنحاول ان نفهم في النقاش لماذا بدات منذ
الجمعه الماضيه هذه المظاهرات في الصين
احتجاجا على سياسه السفر كوميدي مظاهرات
طارت الجامعات في اكثر من مدينه ورفعت
فيها شعارات تنتقد الرئيس الصيني بعد شهر
فقط
ما هي الاوراق البيضاء التي يرفعها
المتظاهرون في اشاره الى تكميم الافواه
حتى الامم المتحده تدخلت لتطالب السلطات
بالسماح
هل نجحت سياسه سفر كوفيد ام زادت من
الشعور
بالاختناق سعيد بان يكون معي في الاستديو
محمود زريق وبروفيسور في علم الاوبئه
والصحه العامه في جامعه ضرسه سعيد بان
تكون معنا من بكين سعاد يعيشين هو وهي
صحفي
وسعيد بان يكون معنا من الرباط طارت
ليساوي واستاذ علوم سياسيه متخصص بشان
الصيني اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا
البرنامج نستمع لمقالته المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
الحاله التي تصفونها لا تعكس حقيقه ما حدث
الصين اتبعت سياسه حيويه تتمثل بصفر كوفد
واجر التعديلات على اساس الحقائق الموجوده
على الارض لا طالما رحبت الصين بصحفيين
الاجانب الذين ياتون لتغطيه الاحداث
واجراء تقارير صحفيه في الصين وفقا
للقوانين المتبعه وقد بذلت الكثير لتسهيل
تغطيهم وتوفير وسائل الراحه لهم لكن في
الوقت نفسه يتوجب على الصحفيين الاجانب
للالتزام الصارم بالقوانين والقواعد
الصينيه عند القيام بعملهم في الصين
نريد تدابير مستند على البحوث العلميه
[موسيقى]
نريد استعاده حياتنا السابقه ما قبل
الجائحه
في بكين سعاد سعاد ما الذي يجري في الصين
كل وسائل الاعلام في العالم تتحدث عن هذه
المظاهرات عن عشرات الالف في الجامعات وفي
كل مكان الكل من هذه الاجراءات التي تتخذ
ومنع الناس من الخروج
مساء الخير تحياتي الى الجميع
للوباء لابد ان نفهم ما السياسه السنيه
العامه في هذا الشهر تتخذ سيناء حاليا
السياسه ااا صفر كوفيه الذين نكيه وهذا لا
يعني تحقيقه تسجيل في حاله الاصابات بشكل
مطلقه
ايه الدوله ان تحقق ذلك حاليا
ان الدول في العالم قد تركت او خففت شديده
لسيطرد على الوباء بدلا من التعايش مع
الفيروس لكن هذه الحاله
المتوافقه مناسبه مع الوضع الثاني
همم يمكن اعرف ان سيدنا هي من هي الدوله
يعني همم التي ما زالت في انتقاد
الاجراءات شديده لسيطره على الودائق ونقول
دائما ان حسين حكومه وشعبا قد بدل تقصار
جهرها خلال 30 سنوات
بشكل كامل مع تركيبات على حكومه وعلى حساب
تركي فرسه
هناك مشاكل
الصحيه يعني 10 اشخاص توفوا لانه شبه حريق
في مبنى ولم يتمكنوا اصلا من الخروج
سبب سياسه الاغلاق وهذا ربما ما زاد من
قلق الصينيين
جدا في همم يعني مدينه الاردن
حسب يعني اخر الاخبار
الصادره من الاجهزه المعنيه فهناك بعد
الاسباب وليس من بسبب الحر الساحب فقط
هناك يعني كان همم
يكون هناك همم الطريق
الممر الى المبنى همم يعني ضايق وكان هناك
الكثير من السيارات الخاصه على جانبي
الطريق وبعد كده يعني هناك مشاكل
طبعا يعني همم المشاكل الناجمه همم ترتيب
ولكن هذا الليس السبب الوحيد
لظهور وحدوث بيتنا هذا الحدب الحزين
طارق عفوا من الرباط انت يعني تعرف الصين
جيدا اكثر منا جميعا واشتى في الصين و
درست في الصين وتعرف العقليه الصينيه
صراحه يعني بعد احداث عن 89 كنت تتصور ان
تسمع ما تسمع الان عما يجري في الصين
ما تنقله وخاصه وسائل الاعلام بسبب هذا
الحجر الصحي هناك عقليه تغيرت بعد الكوفيت
حتى في الصين
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته تحيه
لضيوفكم الكريم وتحيه لك
الواقع
النداء ما اكرر هذه العباره ان كل شيء في
الصين بخصائص الصينيه
من الصعب اسقاط
الرؤيا الغربيه على الصين حقيقه 89 احداث
ينتامين احداث الطلاب التي خرجوا والصوره
الشهيره التي لا زالت في الاذهان صوره ذلك
الشاب الذي تعرض للدم
نعم دبابات دبابات
نعم تعرض للدبابه
هذا الحدث ادى الى تغييرات جوهريه في
الصين
معك اريد ان اسالك عن اذنك مساله صفر
كوفيت هل هي سياسه ناجعه في مكافحه هذا
الفيروس
اول شيء شو معنى
استراتيجيه السفر
الاساسي الاول استراتيجيه انه لا نفعل شيء
نترك الفيروس
لاني بكون تاثير مثلا على
المرضى تاثير وعلى الوضع الصحي قليل جدا
مثل مثلا نزلات البرد
ثاني شيء هي سياسه ما يسمى سياسه التخفيف
يعني شو معناتها من الليل همم تاثيره
بنقلل الانتشار او الجرثومه بالمجتمع حتى
نقلل تاثيره على الموضوع على العدد
الوفيات على
الهداءات باللقائيه مثلا الامراض
المعويه والهضميه
بالامراض الانسانيه الفيروسيه
التنفسيه عن الكمامات عن طريق غسل الايدي
اليوسي همم ايدام وهذا ما ما بشكل عام ما
ما نفعله وقت الانفلونزا الموسميه همم
وما تفعله الان الدول الاوروبيه بالكوفيت
ثالث هو سياسه ما يسمى سياسه الازاله يعني
ما بدنا نخفف بدنا نخفف بشكل كامل انتشار
وهذا ما ما ما همم نقوم به الصين بالسفر
ثاني بنسويه همم سياسه السفر مثل مثلا
حتى تنزل على السفره وحتى تختفي سياسه
السفر
[موسيقى]
لحوالي سنه وما بعد السنه الاولى
الصين عن طريق اغلاق الحدود
سويتها الدول الاخرى كدول الديمقراطيه مثل
استراليا متن نيوزيلندا الجديده مثل
تايوان مثل اليابان وفينا نقول انه بشكل
عام
نجحت لاني عدد صحيا يعني عدد الحالات كان
قليل عدد الوفيات كان قليل عدد الايام
الحجر الصحي كان قليل والمدارس بشكل عام
كانت مفتوحه
المعطيات وقت وقت
المتحول الفرعي همم لان انت شعر وسريع جدا
جدا
وحوالي عشر مرات اكثر
يعني كمان صافي اللقاحات
هلا اذا اخذنا من من تسع شهور شو صار
بالصين
مع سياسه السفر
العام
يحدوا من الانتشار لان اذا بتاخذ عدد
الحالات اليوم اليوم بالصين في حوالي 40
الف حاله نفس عدد الحالات
بفرنسين 20 مره ضعف عدد سكانه همم
ولكن ما يحدث من لا يمكن انه يستمع لاني
الاجراءات ال همم طبعا ما احكي على الوضع
الصحي ضيوفك سيتكلم والحتما عن الوضع
السياسي والوضع والوضع الاقتصادي
للكوفيد ما بس الحجم الصحي او العفن ال-
السفر الجديد ما بس قول له تاثير على
الكوفيد تاشيره همم ايجابي له تاثير على
الامراض الاخرى غير الكوفي لان الولد
بيسيب حاجه صح يمد المسار بيبقى زمان
للاشخاص ما بقى فينهم على المشافي
لمرضى السكري صعب يروحوا يشوفوا طبيب
وشعبي يشوفوا همم علاج همم الحوامل ما فيه
رعايه كامله تشخيص السرطانات مثلا بده
يتاخر لاني
طبعا هذا له تاثير سلبي جدا على على على
ما سيحدث بعد ان كان معنا طارق طارق معذره
واتمنى ان يكون الاستديو في وضع جيد حتى
تتمكن من التدخل معنا لانه قطع في اكثر من
منابتين تفضل تفضل طارق وصل كنت تتحدث عن
الصين
نعم هل تسمعني
باحداثيات 89
اسست لعقد اجتماعي بين الشعب الصيني
والحزب الشيوعي قياده الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني اساسها التنميه مقابل بعض
التنازلات عن الحريات المدنيه والسياسيه
الان ونحن نشاهد امام اعيننا احتجاجات
واسعه في مجموعه من المدن
يعني ضد سياسه سيفر كوفيد وهذا حدث لهما
بعده في الصين خاصه وان القياده الصينيه
تتعامل بجديه مع مثل هذه الاحتجاجات وخاصه
في ظل ظرفيه ان الاقتصاد الصيني يمر من
ازمه او لنقل همم في معدل النمو الصين
التي بنت همم شرعيتها الحزب الشيوعي الذي
بنى شرع وعلى اساس معدلات نمو تتعددت سعود
في المئه الان
الحكومه في افضل توقعاتها تحدد خمسه في
المئه لهذه السنه لكن ما تحقق على الارض
اقل من هذا بكثير والذي اسهم في هذا هو
سياسه صفر كوفيد لكن هل
سيؤثر ذلك على الحكومه ام لا هذه مساله
اعتقد بالعوده الى المؤتمر الاخير المؤتمر
الحزب الشيعي سنجد بان نعم ان الرئيس
الصيني الذي اعيد انتخابه لولايه ثالثه
وايضا تم احداث تاديلات في الدستور الصيني
رفعت من من فكره الرئيس الحالي الى درجه
الى نفس مرتبه رئيس ماو
وتشاوبينج مؤسس الصين الحديثه
فالرئيس الصيني شيء يؤثر شرعيته على اساس
سياسه صفر كوفيد وكمان قال البروفيسير في
في الاستديو فسياسه الصين في مواجهه
كوفيد 19 كانت ايجابيه الى حد بعيد مقارنه
بحجم الوفيات في دول اخرى امريكا اوروبا
الى غيرها
فمجموع عدد الوفيات لم يتعداف 4 4 انا ما
اعتقد اذن فهو رقم
منخفف جدا مقارنه ما بقي البلدان ومقارنه
بحجم بحجم الصين التي تتعدى سكنها المليار
اربع ملايين 400 مليون سنه طيب سعاد يريدك
ان تتفاعلي مما قال من الرباط سعاد ولكن
اريد ان اسالك هو في حضور الاستاذ هنا
بروفيسور المتخصص في الهواء في الاستديو
يعني لماذا عملت الصين ورفضت اطلاقا تلقي
اي لقاح من الغرب وفضلت ان تعتمد فقط على
اللقاء الصينيه وهناك حتى من المتظاهرين
من القول لهم على السلطات الصينيه في هذا
المجال
الدكتور قبل قليل في الاوعيه يعني انا
مكافاه ان الاجراءات الشديده في الاخلاق
التامه همم يعني كانت تسهم كثيرا في
بكافيه
المرحله الاوليه لمكافاه الوباء في
الحقيقه يعني يمكن يعني مثل ذاكره همم
يجب علينا ان نلاحظ ان الودع همم يعني انا
الوضع همم
اولا يعني عدده كبير جدا الذي همم وايضا
يعني بما فيه عدد كبير من المسلمين
يبلغ عدد سكان الذين تملكه اعمالهم السكين
عامه اكثر من همم
مليون وتجاوز عدد قال 200 و50 مليار واحد
ثاني المجموعه هذه كبيره هذه جدا في
السينما اعتقد ان هذا العدد الكبير وكما
نعرف ان عدد سكان للكبير من الدول الغربيه
لم يتجاوز 100 100 مليون نسمه لكن للفيروس
يؤثر على المسنين
بالغيره
او للوفاه وخاصه
الذين يتعرضون لامراض المزمنه وهذا يعني
كده انا هذا همم هو همم
يدفع
هذا همم اجراءات همم شديده يعني مفيده
سيفر ادينا ذكيه همم
اخرى يعني على اجمالي للموارد الطبيه
لسيناطير كافيه ومستوى تتهور لمختلف
المناطق وخاصه في مجال التربيه متوافد
وغير متوازن مثل الموارد ضروريه لغرفه
في موازنه الاحيان يكون هناك ريحه حزام
كبير من الناس في المستشفيات العامه
واذا انتشر الوباء
بامراض خطيره لا يستطيعون
ضروري في المستقبل
وهذا يعني بشهاده الاختيار وحتى عدد
الوفيات لا نعرف ان كان الحديث رسميا عن
4000 ولكن لا ندري صراحه كم
لم ترد على سؤال اللقاح في عده لقاحات
صيني مابس لقاحات في عده لقاحات صينيه
فعاليه اللقاحات الصينيه
كل كل اللقاح
المشروعات العلميه عن اللقاحات
ومودعنا همم ومع الدراسات
من الحالات الخطره بالنسبه الى اللقاحات
الصينيه عدد المشروعات العلميه قليله جدا
لهلا ما معروف بشكل كامل همم
بالامارات جروب
وممكن نتسائل كمان اذا كانت السلطات
الصحيه الصينيه
بدها سياسه السفر كوفيد مع الاجراءات
بتاثر على الصحه
هل هناك شك بفعاليه اللقاح حتى بصوا لهذه
الدرجه من انه ما بدهن
وبعدين الاحصائيات قليله جدا حتى صعب كثير
تعرف نسبه الملقحين نسبه الملقحين الان ما
نعرفه ان هناك من قبل الذين تتجاوز
اعمارهم 70 سنه بالنسبه
اللقاح الثالث اعتقد انه نسبه اقل
بشكل عام بالصين وبالشاق الاوسط بشكل كبير
في
بشير تحذر من اللقاحات بشكل عام
ما لنا ثقه بفعاليه الصين احد الدول هيك
الدول العربيه كما في كمان في كمان حذر من
اللقاحات والصين احد البلاد
لاحد خصوصيات الصين انه الاشخاص المسنين
لاشخاص اللي عندهم اطلاق لقاحات لا تتجاوز
حوالي 20 بالمئه
همم قليل جدا جدا
ماذا سيحدث همم بانتشار الكعونا
للكرونه لا يمكن الا بده ينتشر الا بده
لازم تكون سياسه الدوله طبعا الصين بدها
تتراجع عن سياسه
اسباب صحيه لاسباب سياسيه لاسباب
الهدف الهدف انه يصير تقليل الحالات
الخطره وتقليل الوفيات تقليل الحالات
الخطره تقريبا وفيات افضل شيء هو عن طريق
اللقاح عن طريق اللقاحات وبنتمنى انه
يكونوا مفيده والسلطات الصينيه الصحيه
قالت انه حتى تكون اللقاحات مفيده لازم
ثلاثه جرعات ثلاث جرعات
بيموتوا اكثر شيء
نسبه لقاحات كثير كثير اكثر من الفتره
عندك مليار 400 مليون شخص
اكبر خزان في العالم
هناك علاقه علاقات همم قريبه بين البشر
والحيوانات الاليفه والحيوانات البريه
وبيكون همم على الاغلب انتقال من طريق
الحيوانات البريه للانسان وبالتالي ممكن
يصير همم
ظهور متحولات جديده اكثر ربما اكثر خطوره
طرق اللساوي يعني نحن في الصين اذا في
امكانيه ان تفرض الحجر بهذه الطريقه
بالنظر الى طبيعه السياسه
الصينيه ولكن هذا الملل الذي حصل خاصه في
الجامعات لدى الطلاب هناك نوع من الرفض
لمثل هذه القرارات هناك امتعاض كبير من
ذلك يعني المواجهه بين السلطه والشعب انت
كيف قراتها لان الان هناك نوع من الرفض
والمعارضه الصريحه لهذه الاجراءات
بدايه لابد من الاقرار ان المظاهرات التي
شهدتها
مدن
معقل
شراره هذه الثورات بدات بسبب كما اشرت في
بدايه
تسمعوني استاذ
معقل بدايه هذه الشراره
بذلك الحريق الذي حصل في مجمع سكني في
عاصمه
والذي ذهب ضحيته 10 اشخاص وتم الربط بين
ااه سياسه صفر كوفيت والحجر الصحي ووفات
هؤلاء ضحايا اذن كما يقول في في سؤالك هل
هل سيتم كيف سيتعامل الشعب الشعب الصيني
ملا من ثلاث سنوات من الحجر الصحي ومن هذه
السياسه
باكلها وجنبه البلاد كثير من الماثر لكن
مثلا شانجاي التي شهدت مظاهرات مش محدوده
مقارنه مع شهدتهم مجموعه من المدن
الاوروبيه في مصر السابقه على همم الحجر
الصحي يعني مظاهرات محدوده باوراق بيضاء
وفي ذلك دلاله همم دلاله يعني المواجهه
بين الشرطه كانت محدوده لكن مدينه شنغهاي
مثلا شهدت في بدايه السنه حجر لمده شهرين
هذا اجابه
باضافه الى ان سياسه صفر كوفيد بدات تؤثر
في في الاقتصاد الصيني معدل البطاله يرتفع
في وسطه الشباب هناك ازمه مواكبه تشهدها
الصين هي ازمه عقاريه قد تنذر بندلاء ازمه
ماليه خطيره كل هذه المتغيرات همم دفعت
الشارع الصيني الى الدعوه والمطالبه
بضروره تخفيف القيود لان كورونا هذا الشعب
ليس منفصل على ما يحدث في العالم همم يرى
بان الكمامه التي كانت مفروضه على اغلب
بلدان العالم لم تعد تم رفع القيود اذا
هناك نوع من الشعب الصيني للاحداث رغم ما
تفرضه الحكومه الصينيه في اعلامها وما
تروجها الا ان الشاب الصيني همم منفتح
بان همم اغلب البلدان
اتخذت اجراءات في طريق تحفيز الاقتصاد في
طريق الحد من هذه الاجراءات الصارمه للحد
من الفيروس
كالحكومه بدورها يعني الحكومه بدورها في
مؤتمر المؤتمر الاخير ااا ادخلت بعض
التعديلات على سياسه صفر كوفيد
واشارت في ورقه لا تتضمن 20 نقطه تخفيف
هذه الاجراءات بغرض التحفيز النمو
الاقتصادي
وتحريره واخراجه من دوره البطئ والركود
لكن هل سنرى تفاعلا اكبر من قبل القياده
الصينيه هذه الايام كفيله
بالاجابه عن هذا السؤال لكن من خلال
التجربه والملاحظه استطيع ان اقول بان
الصين العقليه والسيكولوجيه الصينيه
مغايره تماما عمان نعرفه ببقي البلدان
فالقياد الصينيه لن ننتظر منها ان تخرج
لتقول بانني تراجع عن سياسه صفر كوفيت
ولكن سيتم من الان همم اتخاذ بعض التدريب
الاجراءات والتدابير على المستوى المحلي
حكومه الاقاليم رفع بعض الحواجز بهدف
انتصار فهذا الغضب الشعبي الذي بدا كره
الثلج تكبر بالتدريج تنتقل من مدن الى
اخرى
في الايام القادمه سعاد اذا هناك مثل ما
قال الضيف من الرباط هناك افتتاح من قبل
الشباب الصيني على الخارج من خلال وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هل بدات في الصين فكره
رفض قرارات الزعيم الواحد والاوحد وانه هو
الذي يملك الحقيقه ولا احد يملكها غيره
وبالتالي هناك نفس جديد للقول لا نحن لا
رايي ونريد ان نشارك حتى في حياتنا
اليوميه مع الجميع وهل لا تبقى سلطه واحده
تفرض الراي الواحد
اه وعد كده انا يعني عندما نتحدث عن مثل
هذا الشيء يمكن ان نلاحظ كيف تحاول
المشاكل الناجمه او مكافحتها او اعتقد ان
هذا ليس ساعده بالنسبه للسير فقط بلا انها
مشكله كبيره امام دول اخرى وكان في بدايه
الشهر
الغربيه التي اتخذت ايضا
لان هذا يعتبر افضل طريقه
فعاله وكان لا يوجد هذا فعال ولا يوجد
عدويه ما ادى الى المظاهرات وواحده في هذه
الدول طبعا قليله بدنا الدول التي ما زالت
في سيطرات عليك
ولكن يجب علينا ان نلاحظ ان ذلك ليس بسبب
ان الناس يتعاودون على التعايش معلومات
معلومات
لا يريدون مكافحه هذا من جهه ومن جهل اخرى
ليس دسسين دوله واحده تقوم بمكافعه الوباء
بل انا المناظمه للساحه العالميه ما زالت
تدعو الناس الى لباس القنوات في الاماكن
العامه واعتقد انه يعني ان الشعب الصيني
قد تعاون ودعتها عمل مع الماء همم يعني
همم
تتخذوه الحكومه الصينيه في مكافحه
الموضه
اشرحي لنا ما معنى رفع الاوراق البيضاء
يعني ماذا يعني لا تسمح لنا بان نعرب عن
راينا انتم بصدد منعنا من التعبير انتم
بسدد منعنا من الكتابه انتم
محاوله ايصال رسالتنا ما معنى هذه الاوراق
البيضاء المرفوعه من غير متظاهرين
انا هذا الشيء يعني
انا شخصيا لا يمكن ان اشرح لكم ما هذا
يعني مثل هذا الرجل
اوقات
بشكل جيد جدا
انا شخصيا اعيش
انا يعني همم تعرضت همم يعني همم
مرارته بالحرده
كان هناك يعني همم الحمايه ودمنه للموارد
الدائريه التي
وكان لا يوجد مشكله في العيش
واعتقد انا يعني الصينيين همم في همم في
بعض مدن التي اعتقدت الحوله الساحل
لمكافحه النوضاء خلال
سنوات
لذلك فا لا يعني خلال همم فتره ماضيه لما
همم
ممكن تكون صعبه بالنظر الى عدد السكان في
الصين يعني لانه حدد نسبه مئويه معينه
يعني هذا صعب خاصه غير موجوده السؤال موجه
اليك همم بروفيسور هنا الوباء يعود للصين
فماذا عن الدول التي تقول انها حصلت
شعوبها بالسينوفا
سؤال صعب بكل سؤال صعب دائما بيكون
[ضحك]
اللقاح السينما نفعل قلت اللقاح الصيني ما
عنا معلومات
حوالي 600 700 مليون شخص اذا ما في
معلومات لازم تحط معلومات علميه انا عارف
قديش كان اللقاح كان اللقاح
الدول التي استخدمه
وفي منه همم
يطلعوا مع حافظ مع الوجه لان هذا السؤال
لا يمكن يقول انه بدنا نتراجع عن سياده لا
تراجع طبعا على الاقل
قولا بالقول ممكن انه يتراجعوا بالفعل
عمليا
وبعدين وبعدين بنظره الصحه العالميه لبس
القناعتها السفر الجديد
[موسيقى]
من اسباب الوقايه من سياسه التخفيف همم
بالاماكن العامه بالاماكن المغلقه حتى
للاشخاص من اقلل من العدوى من اقل من همم
من الحالات القطر من الاشخاص بالعنايه
المركزه
وبنحاول نتعايش مع الفيروس حتمن همم
الفيروس يعني بشكل كبير الا اذا تم اغلاق
كامل للبنات ولا يمكن اقتصاديا الصين همم
مش هو بهذا الوضع طيب تعرف السؤال بيشكل
مباشر وبشكل المباشر يعني اكثر من مباشر
يعني
مساله صفر كوفيت هل يمكن هذه السياسه في
بلد يوصف بالديمقراطي هل يمكن ان نطبق ذلك
مثلا في فرنسا وفي الولايات المتحده لان
طبعا ستقول لي ان هناك ديمقراطيه على
الطريقه الصينيه بس خلينا في الديمقراطيه
على الطريقه الغربيه هل هذه السياسه ممكنه
ان لم تكن توجد سلطه لها ما لها فيما
يتعلق بمساله الحريات الفرديه والجماعيه
اوضح من هيك ما فيش
[ضحك]
ههه ان الديمقراطيه في العالم العام بعد
كفيت اصبحت محله
نعم الواقع يعني مجموعه تم تم تم تم القفز
عن مجموعه من الحقوق المدنيه والحريات
المدنيه والسياسيه هذا واقع ولا يمكن
انكاره في اعراق الديمقراطيات اما ان يتم
تطبيق ما حدث في الصين في باقي البلدان في
الفعل فقط الم يتم الحجر الميتم باغلاق
الم يتم تقييد حريه الصحافه حريه الاعلام
لكن الذي المغير هو ان هذه البلدان فتحت
على مواطنيها وفتحت الفضاء العام وخففه من
الاجراءات الى اخر ذلك لكن الصين مستمره
في سياسه صفر كوفيت والغريب ان حجم
العصابات اليومي همم في احصاء همم
اليوم عدد الاصابات 40,000 اصابه وكما قال
بروفيسور فافر فرنسا فيها تقريبا ازيد
منها 40,000 يعني 46 يعني مقارنه تناسبا
مع حجم ساكنه الصين في هذا الرقم لا يعني
شيئا همم ولكن مع ذلك الحكومه الصينيه
متمسكه باجراءاتها همم لكن الشعب الصيني
قد مل من هذه الاجراءات
وبدا اه ينتقد
ربطا بسؤالك الاستاذه سعاد عن عن دلاله
همم الاوراق البيضاء
والزهور بيضاء ساحاول الاجتهاد بالعوده
الى همم ارث الثوره الثقافيه فهذه الثوره
الثقافيه ثم حمل الورود
للاحتجاج
وينبغي ان لا ننسى ان هذه الرساله بنظرهم
مشاهده الرئيس الصيني هذا الرئيس الصيني
احد ضحايا الثوره الثقافيه التي حصلت في
في الستينات القرن الالماضي
وتضررت اسرته الى اخر وهو شخصيا
فربما هؤلاء المواطنين الصينيين يحملون
هذه الورود وهذه الاوراق البيضاء لانها
لها دلاله في الثقافه الصينيه فهم
قالوا الكثير واعتقد ان القياده الصينيه
قرات هذه
الدلاله وتحاول الاستجابه نعم رساله
مقروءه بالنسبه للقياده الصينيه
منطقيين طيب سعاد بالنظر الى ما عرفتك في
خصوصيه الديمقراطيه الصينيه هل تعتقدين
انه الان في القياده الحاليه للصين توجد
ارض خصبه
لعقليه من شانها ان
تلجا الى نوع من المراجعات خاصه
عندما هل تهتم اصلا بوسائل الاعلام
الغربيه على غرار صحيفه ليمون في الصفحه
الاولى ال- ال- هذا المساء عن الصين
ومختلف الصحف وتتحدث عن هذه المدارات هل
السلطه في تركيبتها جاهزه للقيام بمراجعات
[موسيقى]
الخاصه
بالديمقراطيه شعبيه كامله
اخرى يجب علينا ان نلاحظه عندما كان هناك
همم يعني همم مثل بعض المشاكل الاجتماعيه
همم التي همم تؤدي او تؤثر على همم على
يعني همم
الاجتماع بالنسبه
غسيل من الوقت لضمان البلاد التي تتمتع
بموارد طبيه واجتماعيه كثيره لمواجهه
انتشار الوباء بشكل شامل مثل اتنافس مع
الوقت للاستعداد بشكل افضل متابعه
دكتور
[موسيقى]
يتحول الفيروس بشكل
مستمر ربما يعني تم تقليل همم
كما تقليل خطوراته بشكل همم
ولكن همم اريد ان الاوضاع مختلفه في كل
الدوله
يعني اذا ذكرته في بدايه ان الزينه تتمادى
عدد كبير من السكان هذا لا يمكن ان نستحان
بها
ولذلك
السياسه كوفيره
هذا الوباء هذا يعني نهج ليس دائما يجب
علينا انه لاهر زينه
يتغير بدلا من ان لاجهزه المعانيه تقوم
حاليا بتعديل وتحسين حسب تغير الوداع
وظروف وتحول الفيروس المستقبل
كان يجب ان لا تدخل السياسه بهذا الشكل في
مصر في الطب وفي الفيروسات ام لا سواء في
الغرب او حتى في الصين الصحه العامه فقط
بالصين يعني حتى حتى يتابعوا السياسي سمن
سيكون هائل على جميع تقصد اقتصاديا
واجتماعيا
وعلى مده قصيره على مده على الاقل اشهر
وهذا وهذا ثمن كبير جدا
لتوقيف هيك فيروس انتشاروه
اسرع من البرق همم يكفي انه يعدد اشخاص
لكل من عدو تقريبا بنفس الوقت بعثتها
المعركه تقريبا
همم اذا ما بدنا نقل الاعداد تقريبا
الى معرفتك على الاقل انت ايضا في في
الثقافه الصينيه
من المؤكد ان هذه المدارات هي اول اختبار
للرئيس الصيني في عهداته الثالثه
وبحكم التجربه اعتقد بان الصين ستعدل
سياستها خاصه وانه هناك وضع اقتصادي
واجتماعي يضغط على الحكومه الصينيه وتم
تداوله بشكل مفصل في المؤتمر الاخير للحزب
الشيوعي في الورقه التي قدمها رئيس تشيك
للمؤتمرين سيتم تراجع على بعض القيود وقد
بدات بالفعل الحكومه في في هذه الاجراءات
خاصه لان النمو الاقتصادي في الصين مساله
مهمه همم الصين همم شرعيه الحزب لها صله
مباشره الاداء الاقتصادي عندما ينخفض نمو
الاقتصادي همم القياده الصينيه تستشعر
الخطر والشعب هناك كما قلت في البدايه
هناك مقايده حدثت لمده 89 بين الشعب
الصيني والقياده الصينيه توسيع خيارات
الناس همم رفع الاداء الاقتصادي لتحسين
الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي البنيه في
مقابل التخلي عن بعض الحريات المدنيه
والسياسيه لذلك دائما واكد واعيد التاكيد
ان الصين لا تفكر بالمنطق الذي تفكر فيه
يا اخي في باريس او في في فاشنتون او
غيرها يعني الخاصيه الخصوصيه الصينيه
مساله ينبغي التعامل معها بجديه في الصين
همم الديمقراطيه همم من العبارات التي
تتكرر كثيرا في الخطاب الرسمي الصيني لكن
هل
الديمقراطيه وفق المعايير
الغربيه ام الديمقراطيه وفق المعيار
الصيني يعني حتى الصين يتكلمون عن انه
هناك همم الرئيس الصيني منتخب من قبل
الشعب والحزب الشيوعي له همم قاعده شعبيه
مناصره وخاصه انه ينبغي ويسمح لي ان نفتح
قوس بان همم التاثير الخارجي همم يلعب دور
كبير في في دعم في دعم شرعيه الحزبه
الصيني لان اليوم استمرار الحزب الشيوعي
في الصين
واحتفاظه بنسبه تاييد واسع من قبل الشرق
هو نتاج لهذا الاداء الفعال اليوم حينما
يلاحظ المواطن الصيني ان بلاده تنافس
امريكا وتؤثر في الاسواق العالميه فهو فهو
يشعر به الفخر لان هذه القياده نجحت في
اخراج الصين من من عصر الادلال الذي تعرض
له في اواخر في مطلع القرن العشرين طيب
اعدك بنقاش خاص عن الثقافه الصينيه الشكر
في الختام لي محمود
والصحه العامه في جامعه
الثالثه صباحا يقول لك يوما سعيدا في في
الصين وشكر من الرباط
امامك استاذ علوم سياسيه متخصص بشان
الصينيه شكرا لفريق البرنامج خمسي مريحه
[موسيقى]